146 people have died during a crush in
the South Korea 150 more are thought to
be injured following a stampede at a
Halloween event in the capital Seoul
pictures from the scene show emergency
workers trying to rescue people who
become trapped beneath the dead and
injured ashnaharanag reports and a
warning from the beginning you may find
some of the images in this report
distressing
screams replace the blaring music that
etawan is used to hearing on a Saturday
night
is
hundreds of propelled forwards in an
uncontrollable surge
[Applause]
quickly turns to fear as hordes of
people funnel down the Narrow Street
crushing hundreds as they move
emergency service workers here try to
dislodge the bottleneck with people
piled on top of each other in images too
distressing to show bystanders and
paramedics attempt to resuscitate
motionless people on the ground and
blankets cover the Dead
others try to disperse the crowds more
than 100
000 people were thought to be in the
area for Halloween celebrations a
popular district for the city now
swarming with Emergency Services
bolstered efforts too With Disaster
Medical Teams
tonight on social media prime minister
Rishi sunak sent a message of sympathy
to the people of Seoul
the number of dead and injured continues
to climb
the impact of this Saturday night of
horror is only just being felt Ashna
harinag Sky News